the lack of fight or financial nursing
in this country is really or the
terminology or the definition is very
broad base it's you know about how to
budget your money and live within your
means it's about saving a certain
portion of your income for your entire
life it's about you know managing credit
card debt
you're not having more than say 36
percent of your income and too much debt
it so it means also having proper
insurance and having a will so it's it's
it cuts across so many different factors
of your life and if anything gets out of
whack it can really ruin you personally
financially financial literacy is
broad-based
knowledge around all aspects of finances
in your life personal finances and it's
the underpinning or the foundation for
what we call financial fitness so first
you've got to have the knowledge but
then you have to behave and act up
properly or yeah properly around around
this this knowledge so that means you
know saving for entire life that means
you know keeping within your budget it
means not getting into too much debt so
you want to have the knowledge and you
want to have the behaviors and that's
what creates fitness financial fitness
and a 30 year old made his financial
fitness may be very different than say a
fifty-five or sixty six year old